the field of engineering has a huge
influence on how we live our lives
pretty much everything around us has
been engineered in some way from the
infrastructure that keeps countries
running roads water energy to the
buildings we live in to the things we
use every day our devices books even the
clothes on our backs
this map of engineering is my attempt to
capture all of those different areas of
engineering and try and put them all in
one place so that we can get our heads
around it all
and like all of my maps you can buy it
as a poster from dosmaps.com as well as
our professor astrocat books
we'll start with civil engineering which
I like to think of as the engineering of
big stuff that doesn't move
civil engineering encompasses large
public works like Bridges tunnels dams
roads airports Railways and pipelines
for things like water supply and water
treatment as well as a whole host of
other infrastructure that helps our
countries and economies tick along
generally they're built to stay in place
and last a long time
civil engineering was called civil
engineering in the past to distinguish
it from military engineering which are
both the oldest branches of engineering
early examples of civil engineering
projects were related to farming and the
control of water sources
but also building settlements towns
cities and large vanity projects like
the Great Pyramids at Giza
coming back to today arguably the
largest Collective engineering projects
are our cities which involve surveying
to measure and assess the land on which
buildings are built architectural
engineering which deals with the design
of buildings including the planning for
their construction and operation when
inhabited Structural Engineering ensures
that buildings are safe and are strong
under their own weight and can withstand
environmental effects like earthquakes
or extreme weather events
Structural Engineering doesn't just
apply to buildings but any structures
humans build for example it's a key part
of building dams to withstand the large
pressure of water behind them
most civil engineering projects need
large amounts of surface materials like
soil or Rock to be moved and this
processing is called Earthworks
and geological engineering applies
geological science to support other
engineering projects assessing their
geological suitability for large
projects things like dams or mining
sites amongst others
and understanding corrosion and the
breakdown of materials over time is
really important to make sure that
systems are maintained and don't have
catastrophic failures
this is a good time to point out that
engineering by its very nature is
largely cross-disciplinary where just
about everything on this map will also
involve many other areas of this map
for example the planning of building a
building falls under the remit of
architectural engineering but it will
also draw on Structural Engineering for
the physical Integrity of the building
which also draws on materials
engineering for the properties of the
materials the building will be built
from which in turn these materials will
have been developed using techniques
from chemical engineering then the
systems inside a building will draw on
mechanical engineering for air
conditioning and elevators and
electrical engineering for light and
power and computer engineering to
control everything and for security
so even though I've had to separate
everything into categories in this map
please remember that in reality there
are strong connections between all of
these areas so many in fact that I
wasn't able to draw them all out as it
would just turn into a giant mess
okay back to civil engineering
agricultural engineering and biosystems
Engineering apply engineering science to
agricultural purposes to improve the
efficiency and yield of farms growing
food it also applies to businesses in
the bio economy growing crops for things
like biofuel and is also used with a
goal of increasing the sustainability of
these processes
environmental engineering looks at ways
of improving the quality of the
environment for living organisms by
finding ways to reduce pollution in the
ground water and air
and also looks at the best ways of
managing the waste material Humanity
produces controlling landfill or the
safe containment of hazardous waste like
chemical or radioactive waste or how to
recycle materials to be reused again
the power and energy systems applying
our electricity also fall under civil
engineering as well as the many
different Power stations which produce
the energy like nuclear power plants and
others
closely related is petroleum engineering
which involves the exploration and
exploitation of oil reserves which also
Supply Power stations as well as turning
the oil into various petroleum products
like gasoline aircraft Fuel and anything
made out of plastic
but now we've wandered into the Realms
of chemical engineering
I like to think of chemical engineering
as the shuffling about of molecular
bonds
chemical engineering deals with
developing methods to convert raw
materials into useful materials that can
be used for many different commercial
purposes
it involves the design building an
operation of chemical process plants
which create the useful materials
one example is taking the raw materials
from mining operations and processing
that material to create pure chemicals
for example lithium for the battery
industry
just about all of the products we buy
have some kind of chemical engineering
involved in their production the food we
eat is likely to have been fertilized
with nitrogen fertilizer a product of
the chemical engineering industry also
the chemicals that make cosmetic
products paper products made from trees
anything made of plastic metal or
ceramic have had some kind of chemical
engineering involved in their materials
even things made of wood have mostly had
some kind of chemical treatment be it a
stain or varnish
another example of the clothes we wear
which go through a process to convert
raw materials like cotton wool or
Plastics into woven flexible materials
that can be tailored into stylish garb
and of course chemical engineering
creates commodity and Specialty
Chemicals which are used for all kinds
of commercial in the industrial
processes
finally everyone's favorite chemical
engineering fermentation which straddles
the line between chemical engineering
and bioengineering is it uses biological
organisms yeasts and bacteria to create
the tasty booze humans are somewhat
enamored with as well as delicious
things like tea coffee chocolate bread
yogurt kimchi and natto amongst many
others
and industrial fermentation harnesses
microbes for the large-scale production
of chemicals like biofuels enzymes
proteins and pharmaceutical drugs
bioengineering or biological engineering
combines the knowledge and principles of
biology with engineering and this has
two main approaches either by harnessing
biological systems or designing systems
for use in cooperation or within
biological systems many of which are
used in the field of biomedical
engineering which is the part that's
focused on medicine
biological Engineers can use biological
systems cells bacteria viruses and
manipulate their behavior or genetics
for specific purposes for example
engineering the metabolic pathway of
bacteria to create specific chemicals or
biomolecules or the manufacture of
vaccines or antibiotics or drugs which
fall under the remit of
biopharmaceuticals
other applications of bioengineering
include tissue engineering where the
task is to create biological tissues
that can be used to restore or replace
damaged tissues or in the most advanced
cases whole organs
in the realm of biomedical engineering
is the fabrication of Prosthetics which
are designed to replace a missing body
part or to increase functionality or
freedom of movement
inside the body implantable medical
devices like artificial hearts or
pacemakers also fall within biomedical
engineering
and finally there are the creation of
tools to help the medical field
including medical imaging technology and
diagnostic devices to detect various
ailments
now on to mechanical engineering
you can think of mechanical engineering
as the engineering of things that move
but actually I think it might be the
engineering of energy because so much of
it involves converting one form of
energy to another to do something useful
mechanical engineering involves the
design production and operation of
machines with moving Parts like Wheels
levers gears pumps but these moving
Parts need to be powered in some way by
some form of energy
a familiar example are engines which
burn a fuel source like coal or gasoline
which releases the chemical energy and
turns it into motion which then can be
harnessed for any other kind of motion
through other Mechanical Devices like
gears chain drives and all other kinds
of Transportation products
also
engineering the word engineering has the
same root in Latin as ingenuity
and Engineering means the product of
Ingenuity which I really like and I
think kind of applies to this whole map
engineering builds products of ingenuity
anyway other examples of energy
converting machines are turbines which
convert mechanical movement into
electrical energy like in wind turbines
or dams generators turn chemical energy
into electrical energy by burning some
kind of fuel and motors which turn
electrical energy into mechanical motion
all of these are useful machines
designed to convert one kind of energy
into another
vacuum technology is also a part of
mechanical engineering dealing with a
pumping of gas from one place to another
to change the air pressure this can
create a suction force in the case of
vacuum cleaners or create an ultra high
vacuum for science experiments
compressors do a similar but opposite
job pumping air or some other gas into a
space making the pressure go higher and
higher this is often used to liquefy
gases to make them more Compact and
easier to transport
a large part of mechanical engineering
is involved in the process of making
large quantities of machines known as
industrial engineering or manufacturing
which are aided of course by other
specialized machines
a familiar example of this is the
automotive industry where Automotive
Engineering deals with the design and
manufacture of cars and other vehicles
materials engineering is a core part of
mechanical engineering because you want
to make your machines out of materials
with the right physical properties to
perform the tasks you want them to
perform strength flexibility weight heat
resistance Etc
but even though I've put materials
Engineering in mechanical engineering
It's actually an important part of
everything on this map because
everything you build is made of stuff
and you want to make sure it's the best
material for the job
materials Engineering also investigates
building entirely new materials with
novel physical properties not found in
other materials and it's got a long
history of revolutionizing the world
that's why ages in history are called
Stone Age Bronze Age or Iron Age and
look at what the invention of plastic
has done to the world
motion is a key function of machines but
sometimes that motion is inadvertently
transmitted to places where it's not
needed or causes damage
this is where the use of vibration
isolation equipment comes in
and non-destructive testing is an
important part of manufacturing to test
the parts that are being produced
without affecting the usability of those
parts
and towards bioengineering we've got
Robotics and mechatronics which are the
design of more general purpose machines
that can help and assist humans for
example industrial robots on production
lines that can be programmed to perform
specific tasks or robots that can
replicate human actions or even entirely
replace Humanity in the future they also
have a range of different sensors to
make sense of their environment and some
kind of artificial intelligence to make
decisions about what to do next and guns
finally as we get close to electrical
engineering we've got electromechanical
engineering an area robotics makes heavy
use of it involves the interaction or
embedding of electrical systems with
mechanical systems and also we have
Micro electromechanical Systems or mems
which covers the technology of
microscopic devices with moving parts
mechanical engineering also finds heavy
use in military engineering and weapon
systems where the energy conversion is
used for more deadly purposes
in general humans don't do very well
when exposed to high levels of kinetic
energy the basic principle of warfare
throughout the ages
anyway moving on to more positive uses
of mechanical engineering we come to
aerospace engineering aerospace
engineering is the branch of engineering
concerned with the development of
aircraft and spacecraft including design
and manufacture of helicopters Rockets
or satellites amongst others and is
highly interdisciplinary building a
rocket needs knowledge of aerodynamics
propulsion materials engineering
avionics chemical engineering electrical
engineering Computer Engineering and
control systems all working together
flawlessly
there are also lots of applications of
mechanical engineering in Marine
engineering which involves the
engineering of marine vessels like ships
boats and submarines as well as any
ocean-based system or structures like
oil rigs and harbors
Marine engineering is closely related to
Naval engineering or Naval architecture
which involves shipbuilding and the
design maintenance and operation of
marine vessels and structures
integral to Marine engineering is an
understanding of fluid mechanics how
water moves and how things move through
water as well as watercraft propulsion
the mechanisms used to create thrust to
move Marine vessels through the water
now on to the last big branch of
engineering electrical engineering
put simply an electrical engineer wants
to control the movement of electrons in
solids to make them do useful things but
really electrical engineering harnesses
the fundamental principles of
electromagnetism which apart from
gravity is basically the only way we
perceive and interact with the natural
world
electrical engineering is a broad field
which utilizes electromagnetism in many
different ways some of which we've
already met like power generation and
distribution in civil engineering and
generators and motors in mechanical
engineering which really could also have
been drawn in electrical engineering
telecommunications takes advantage of
electromagnetic signals these can be
sent through the air like with cell
phone signals or radio or through
electrons and wires like cable TV or
through electromagnetic waves of light
in Optical fibers
today our lives are filled with
electronic devices all of which have
electric circuits inside designed to
perform specific useful tasks
electric circuits are built from a
number of basic units like resistors
capacitors and inductors to produce a
range of complex behaviors
this Blends into computer engineering
which is a subset of electrical
engineering but is a large enough
discipline to have its own section
before we move on to that I want to
mention systems engineering which
actually is not exclusive to electrical
engineering or computer engineering but
anywhere where there's a large complex
system of interrelated Parts like the
electronics in a fighter jet or a
computer system or the power grid or
whole cities
systems engineering looks at how to
design and manage complex systems over
their life cycles I had to put systems
engineering somewhere on this map and
this made the most sense to me because
many applications involve electric
circuits a related discipline is
instrumentation and control engineering
which involves measuring and controlling
certain variables in a system
these variables are known as process
variables and can include things like
speed force temperature pressure rate of
flow humidity and many others
the aim is to measure these process
variables and make changes to a system
to keep the variables within a desired
range an example is a thermostat
controlling the temperature of your room
or cruise control controlling the speed
of your car but these Control Systems
can be incredibly complex like in a
fighter jet or in a robot where the
robot's computer needs to make decisions
based on the data coming in from the
sensors
we also have a few different areas of
electrical engineering which focus on
specific application areas of electronic
devices like broadcast engineering which
deals with radio and television
broadcasting audio equipment engineering
deals with the devices that detect or
create sounds like microphones or
loudspeakers audio engineering also
known as sound or recording engineering
involves recording live performances and
adjusting the electrical signals through
audio devices to equalize volume or mix
and process sounds often for use in the
music and entertainment Industries
I've also put acoustical engineering
here which isn't actually electrical
engineering but I put it here because
it's so close to the last two
disciplines because it's all about
dealing with sound and vibration
he can involve designing concert halls
for excellent Acoustics or reducing
unwanted noise called noise control or
the use of ultrasound in medicine
now onto computer engineering which
combines electrical engineering and
computer science to develop computer
hardware and software to make computers
microcontrollers and other computational
electronic devices
computer systems engineering looks at
how to build computers or computer
components to fulfill specific needs for
example high performance Computing may
require many parallel processes or
efficient software to manage tasks
software engineering is responsible for
all of the code that runs every computer
every computer program and the entire
internet
software engineering is essentially the
job of giving computers step-by-step
instructions which can be written in
various different programming languages
depending on the problem that's being
solved
network engineering and Computing
involves a set of computers either
communicating with each other or sharing
resources and the design and
implementation of that Network so that
it runs efficiently and Carries On
working even if sections of the network
go down
more broadly network engineering is a
key part of telecommunications networks
used by telephones satellites and
Broadcasting
most Engineers working in information
engineering or data engineering have a
software engineering background and use
programming languages to collect and
manage large amounts of data and then
process that data in ways that give
insight about that data Trends patterns
correlations or predictions
the most topical application of
information engineering is machine
learning and AI
but summarizing the data and coming up
with visualizations is also an important
part of information engineering to
interpret and understand the results
and finally I want to cover photonics or
Optical engineering which deals with
light how to detect it or generate
transmit or manipulate it for useful
purposes like displays opto electronic
devices like LEDs or solar panels
medical Optics and Optical components
for scientific research or industry
this is a part of electrical engineering
because it still deals with
electromagnetism but it is distinct
enough because of its focus on light
specifically
so that's the map of engineering
hopefully that gives you a good overview
of the field and of all the diverse ways
that engineering is used to improve our
lives
by historical standards we live like
royalty and I think it's very easy to
take for granted all of our modern
luxuries like water electricity the
internet modern medicine so I think
sometimes it's good to appreciate the
engineers that have step by step built
our modern world
and if you study engineering one of the
things you learn is the engineering
mindset which is a powerful tool to
analyze problems design Solutions and
invent new technology that's never been
built before
this is me on a train what do you think
I'm doing Doom scrolling nope not me I'm
on brilliant brilliant is an educational
app and website where you can spend your
spare moments improving your Knowledge
and Skills at Science and Mathematics a
much better use of your phone time than
the Alternatives do they have courses on
engineering they certainly do as well as
physics mathematics computer science and
many more related disciplines you can do
the courses in your own time at your own
pace and they remember exactly where you
were so you can just jump in and out as
much as you like when I find myself
reaching for my phone in those spare
moments it's really great to have
something productive I can do which is
actually improving myself and without
too much effort all of those little
slices can quickly add up to you
understanding something new it's
definitely helped me test my knowledge
by being forced to actually solve
problems I don't always get them right
but that's okay that's when I learned
something new if you're interested
please go to brilliant.org Dos or just
click on the link in the description
below which lets them know you've come
from here and this helps me out a bit
too thanks so much for watching and
keeping up with my channel and I'll see
you in the next map video